you
[Music]
we'll get started so this is the session
on blockchains so welcome to the session
on blockchains so we have a bunch of
interesting talks in this session so we
have the first presentation will be on a
work that marries traditional databases
with blockchain the second like work
would be on exploring how we can use
computation verification in the setting
of blockchain and then finally we have
another work that explores how we can
use enclaves to kind of achieve better
performance and confidentiality in the
context of block chains so the first
speaker is going to be Professor Carson
burning from technical university of tam
start he's also an adjunct professor at
Brown University and before that he was
an architect at SAP HANA and he's a
recipient of Google faculty award and
and he has a bunch of best paper up
awards that I Triple E Big Data and vldb
and sigmod and he's been recently
exploring the entry or the overlap
between block chains and databases and
he's going to talk about that so the mic
should be on so today I mentioned I'm
talking about so a database view on
cloth chains but so my main research is
actually in general in distributed
databases especially data distributed
Atta basis together with with networks
so I'm a database person just to give
you a quick introduction where I click
where I come from so why I got
interested in block chains is because
people are not using block chains for
cryptocurrencies only but they use block
chains more and more for as general
share databases to write data into from
one trusty domain and access it from
another trusty domain and the main
reason why people are using it as a as a
as a platform for data sharing is there
are many different reasons and one is
because it keeps the history of all
transactions meaning if something is
wrong in your database you can go back
and still look at what went wrong and in
some states in the USA they even change
the
that blockchains or the data in
blockchain counts as evidence in court
so that which is a strong reason if you
share data between trust between
different trusted domains the second one
is why it's interesting is also because
no tempering is possible after the fact
so once the transaction is in you cannot
modify the list of transactions you
store in your in your blockchain and
even more interesting you don't need a
trusted Authority for for making all
these decisions so the machinery in
blockchain is designed in order to to
give you to give you the the two
properties that it's those all
transactions and it's it doesn't allow
tempering without having a trusted
Authority so and you see that it's
actually used as share databases and
there are many applications outside
outside that try actually to use
blockchains already as a share database
and they range from different or cover
different domains not data just in from
from health institutions but also supply
chains where you have different entities
the supplier and manufacturer required
to access the same database but also to
other use cases where you want to have
decentralized copyright management so I
for example bind it as a copyright
management platform for images where you
put in the image it gets a timestamp and
thus it has the copyright and if
somebody else at the end wants to upload
another similar image you have the proof
that the other image was in the database
before so the question is now are we
done now is this the end of the talk so
our existing blockchain systems as they
are good enough for supporting all the
different applications that people have
in mind and when they want to use them
as a share database so what I'm going to
do in the talk is therefore I'm first
going quickly I think most of the people
might know the blockchain basics but I
still go quickly over the blockchain
background some basic terms that I'm not
talking about things that are out of
context in the rest of the talk then
talk about the challenges why
blockchains
in my eyes are not sufficient yet to use
them as a shared database and then go
towards what we've been doing in the
past year with blockchain to be
developing a shared
our database system on top of
blockchains that mitigates some of the
problems that we've seen discussed
before okay so for blockchain is just
the quick overview I don't want to spend
too much time so blockchains at the base
at the basis they use the tamper proof
lecture to store data which I already
mentioned it's a list of transactions is
its append only the transactions are
appended in blocks of new data is
written the new data is appended or
mined in in blocks and the lecture is
fully replicated and here you see
already if some something is mind or
appended in blocks and it's fully
replicated there seems to be a lot of
inefficiency in the system itself and
this is again one of the challenges that
you tackle when you want to use it as a
general-purpose database system the so
for why why or why it's so interesting
as a share database I already mention is
if update happened to the shared
database which is replicated to all the
peers in a blockchain then everybody or
at least the majority depending on what
what protocol you are using needs to
agree on the appends and there are
different ways to assure that if never
mind what you were using if you're using
a public or private blockchain if that's
what I'm also will go over in a few in a
few seconds and the last bit of piece of
information that I'd like to introduce
is the term of smart contracts which are
nothing else than trusted procedures
that are stored in the blockchain that
can modify data it's your custom logic
that you deploy in a blockchain for data
based person it would be something like
a stored procedure that can be called
from from outside but for smart
contracts the specific thing is that all
the participants agree on the same code
if you if you run they're launching a
second slide just only on the just to
get the the background right so there
are two platforms or ways how how block
chains are deployed there are public
block chains of means that everybody
every participant can can show in the
blockchain and they usually use more
expensive consensus protocols I don't go
into into details for those but just to
make
sure that we are on the same side there
are also private blockchains which
target a different type of application
where not everybody is allowed to join
the blockchain but it's it's more
limited set of targeted towards a
limited set of participants that know
each other and therefore they use a bit
of less expensive contentious protocols
and this already increases the
performance a bit when when you use
blockchains as a database system so the
question is that would actually like to
start my talk what are the challenges if
you want to use a blockchain as a block
chains as a shared database system and
the main challenge I already mentioned
that is clearly the performance of block
chains and there was a paper last year
in sigmod where they analyzed the
throughput and the latency of different
blockchain systems one is a theorem that
is pretty well known which is used which
you can set up as a public but also as a
private blockchain as well as hyper
ledger which is the IBM version of the
blockchain system but what you see here
is that the throughput for example for
classical database benchmark so you if
you use the blockchain just as a key
value store is pretty low so they
reported around 4 ëthere iam around 300
transactions per second that can be
executed and if you look carefully in
the paper this is not the average
transaction rate that's the peak
transaction rate so the average
transaction rate is actually much much
lower and so clearly here you see does
that the that that the transaction and
the performance that you get at the
transaction rate the throughput and
latency that you get out of these block
chains is far from what typical
applications need today even if for
example if you look at what Reese is
processing on average so visa
transactions are around 2,000
transactions per second and if you look
into the applications what how people
want to use block chains they also want
to store sensor data in the blockchain
which even require much higher higher
transaction rates so the the performance
itself is one one problem
the second one is if you today want to
use one of the blockchain systems
a shared database you are confronted
with the Sioux of those systems and it's
really not clear which one to use they
come a with different programming and
execution models and the question is
which one is able to at least well with
which platform are able to implement
your logic that you want here for for
for the share database where can you
implement in which can you implement
transactions or the transaction logic
that that is needed for your for your
for a use case and even worse because
there's so much development going on you
don't know what is the best blockchain
for your workload and B which ones will
survive at the end because there's so
much movement in this sector and people
are trying to come up with optimizations
new platforms and it's unclear which one
which one you should build your share
database application on the last one is
even more severe that block chains you
might assume if you deploy your code in
the blockchain and run it you get some
kind because even procedures run through
the consensus mechanism that multiple
nodes need to execute the same code
bases and at the end the output of the
procedure is verified so meaning if all
the outputs are equal but that's not
true for purely read-only functions that
you would implement as in your smart
contract they are only executed by one
peer in the blockchain meaning if that
one peer if that one node is malicious
and you are asking or you sending a rich
request to that one peer you might get
just a wrong value from from the peer
and so the the guarantees you are
getting for four reads for example is
it's not enough from any of the share
database where you want to know it's the
value I've been reading actually the
value that is stored in the database so
there are many guarantees that you
actually then want to add to your
database system or to your if you use
your blockchain as a shared database and
what we were where what what we what we
think would be nice is if you could
execute transactions on a shared block
chain at the end verify if the execution
of the transaction meaning of all your
read and write operations was correct
with regard to the guarantees what the
database wants to give you and if you
discover that a violation happen
happened that you can go back to the
last verified checkpoint so having so
the ideas of transactional theory more
into implemented in in blockchains but
also transactions that are verifiable so
how are we going to achieve this and
this is the idea of blockchain DB the
idea is that we build a middleware on
top of block chains the idea is what the
blockchain DB gives us is that it gives
us a unified API so we tackle the
problem of having a su of those systems
by having a unified front and then an
exchangeable back and similar to what my
sequel is today for databases you get a
you get a unified front and you can plug
in your storage engine that you that you
that you like to have and which gives
you the performance characteristics
maybe that you that you weren't here for
your application the second one is that
you that we can apply typical database
optimizations in the middleware so we
we've seen that performs itself is a
it's a major limitation and by applying
some tricks in the middleware by
shouting across certain block chains we
can achieve much higher throughput than
what the existing block chains give us
already and the last one is that we want
to support this very this notion of
verifiable transaction so executing read
write operations we are the blockchain
DB and then at the end getting the very
verification mechanism that tells us is
that the operation is a transaction that
we've executed it's been correct with
regard to the consistency level for
example selected in the database system
now you could argue okay blockchain
maybe this is a component that runs out
of you're outside of your blockchain so
it's an untrusted component doesn't it
make things harder I'll come to that at
the end and I talked a bit about how we
how we deal with verification with a new
component that is actually untrusted so
what we've actually been building in the
last year is not a full database system
but as a first step we've started to
build a middleware that has a simple put
get interface because this is already
from as a as a basic building block we
think we can we can use later on to
build transactions on top
and B it gives us already proof of
concept how far can we get with
transaction rates if we have just a
simple put get workload so the idea is
we have a blockchain key value store
that supports at the beginning only the
simple put guide operations that we have
here and we have black blue back ends
inside the blockchain in order to
achieve the higher performance and
implement some database optimizations we
selected a bunch of techniques that are
implemented in the middleware bead from
sharding the data into multiple into
multiple block chains so not using just
one this is a thing that already some of
the block chains to find by now inside
the block chain system they support our
shouting but not all of the system
supported so what we can do is just
black put that on top and support that
way some data parallel execution across
block chains because if you look a bit
deeper into the execution models of
block chains they are typically fully
serialize a civilized execution with no
parallel so parallel execution of
transactions at all and the shouting
gives us some some way of paralyzing and
we implemented a bunch of other
optimizations and I want to go just in
two of them and show you quickly what
the performs and impacts are if you if
you if you do that or if you implement
those in the middle where the first one
is so the question is if you provide
food get interface so what consistency
can can we provide if we use it better
if we use a block chain and in block
chain key key value so we support
different notions of consistency levels
or clients like consistency levels that
are more expensive or less expensive and
the idea is that if we give up some of
the consistency similar to what normal
databases also do you can get higher
performance even when we use a block
chain as a back-end and the idea here is
that if you use a higher consistency
level for example read your own rights
what we do in the middle where if a
right is coming in if a put is coming in
its its first submitted to the trail to
the blockchain but we don't wait for the
committee or that the transactions
actually committed but only that it's
validated and after that we just append
it to a list in our in our in
middle layer meaning that once a reed is
coming in for the same key at that
moment we do lazy blocking on on
depending on the pending transaction
wait for the transaction to be committed
before we give back the value so this is
one technique where you already don't
need to wait for the full execution of a
transaction but you still get a
guaranteed consistency level which many
of the applications desire or you can
even go lower and provide only eventual
consistency and even don't wait for the
transaction to be committed and execute
discrete operations completely on the
status you are getting and monitor if
these transactions finally commit so if
you can still guarantee liveliness and
what you see here is that if you
implement just on a using a 50 50 50
we're closed officially reads 50 percent
rights and aetherium
as a back-end if you want to provide
read your own rights semantics you get
only throughput of 20 put get operations
at a second and this is so in line with
with the block bench numbers if you look
a bit closer they reported only numbers
as I said for max throughput and not for
average to see the eventual consistency
gives you already boost of a factor of 5
in in terms of transactions which is not
not still not there what many of the of
the of the application needs but it's
it's already a way of getting getting
higher performance out of your
blockchain system if you if you if you
decrease the consistency level a second
technique that actually is helping much
more is that in our middleware we we
implemented some form of batching so we
don't submit puts one by one to the
blockchain because the power transaction
overhead of validating transactions is
it's pretty high so meaning if he if we
batch them together so multiple puts in
one blockchain transaction you can get
for example if you block up to 500 puts
in one call a transaction rate of 1,200
transactions per second after that the
message size is or the maximum message
size we used here for
integers is exceeded so there's a limit
of patching that you can use so the
plane database tricks is one thing but
the question is now I a third point
which is interest or which is important
that is getting very verifiability of
your operations and this is something
that we also implemented inside
blockchain in or inside our system and
the problem here is or the idea of
verifiable consistency is that a client
can verify the correctness of all
operations meaning if the puts and gets
that he executed and the that he sees or
that that he executed adhere to the
selected consistency level so what does
it mean for eventual consistency it
means for the eventually eventually
consistently that a client doesn't see
any fake reads so if you have if you
think about a scenario where for example
the blockchain middleware or one of the
peers is malicious he might return just
the value that is not stored in your
database we want to be able to detect it
detect it after the fact and if you use
a blockchain system out of the box you
don't get that guarantee and the second
one is that we want to for example or in
eventual consistency we also want to
support life in it so we want to assure
that all the puts that I executed
through blockchain Cavia actually are
actually stored in the blockchain system
and not dropped again by one of the
components so the problem is that as I
mentioned that all these operations are
this guarantees could be violated
because in our in our setup we have
multiple untrusted components one is our
blockchain key values or that we are
introduced as a middleware but there's
also the PS themselves if you look at
them individually are untrusted meaning
if if you just go to one of the peers we
might get the problem of fake fake reads
and reads are actually executed by only
one peer so it's severe or it's a
problem of detecting if you get such if
you get a fake read or if for example
the blockchain middleware or the peer
drops a transaction and doesn't execute
it how we do it is so here just
high-level overview is the ideas that we
use defer to Eric
mechanism where every put that is
executed through the key value store
updates the right set in the in the
blockchain itself and the clients
additionally lock their actions their
read and rights that they don't need to
do it for into each individual call but
they lock the read and write set not
using the middle the middleware layer
but going by passing the middleware they
lock the read their reads and write sets
into the into the into the blockchain as
well the nice point about these cause is
they don't need to be synchronous
blocking you can just send them as
synchronously and at the end of of your
epoch when you are when you execute it
multiple of the puts and gets what you
want to do is also a verification
procedure that looks into the question
if the right set was included that that
the clients reported we are there recall
calls is included in the right set that
the key value store was seen and this is
also again a non blocking operation mean
means we submit that as a blockchain
transaction so implemented as a store
procedures smart contract which checks
if these two guarantees are satisfied
and once we once it's done we can just
fetch the result if the epoch was
correct if all the operations are have
been correct and in worst case rollback
in the transaction history to a point
where no where the where the last
verified epoch was was well store in the
database so we can also recover to two
valid check points good so that there's
much more many more details you need to
think about if you want to do it if a
verification with the blockchain and
there are more details
I haven't been including in the slides
but this is the general notion of how we
want to ensure that put and gets
executed correctly so what are we up to
next so we just as I said it's the first
step what we that we implemented there
are many more optimizations that we
haven't implemented for example caching
in the middleware but still guaranteeing
verifiability that's something we are
working on at the moment but and then
for sure go
in the in the route of having not just
the put gate interface but supporting
full database transactions that on top
of our key value store interface so in
long term what we what we want to
achieve or how we think that the our
middleware could be integrated into a
data management status also have a
combination of a database that is
running on premise where you use the
blockchain a database system to
integrate something like a shared column
into your database into your local
database system meaning you create a
table you mark your column as shared and
by getting the guarantees of verifiable
transactions and sharing on those
columns of data automatically written to
the blockchain and you can verify for
those columns if transactions on those
columns have been right but this is
something we haven't started thinking
about in detail with that I'm at the end
of the talk happy to take questions I'm
sure if we have time for questions at
all so you decided a sigmod paper saying
that even if you set up a private
environment around blockchain and the
throughput is very limited array so I
just intuitively I have a hard time to
understand why this case I wonder if you
share some insight you mean why the
transaction rate of block chains so
depending so I haven't been going into
the into the details of the execution
models of block chains but for example
public block chains use so consensus
protocol which is called proof-of-work
meaning that one was private yeah and
for them as I said so the the complete
transit so for private transact of
private blockchains the problem is that
data a the a train full exit or the
execution of all transactions is fully
serialize meaning one node takes a set
of transactions execute them distributes
the results to all the peers in the
blockchain and they reacts acute the
transactions to verify the outcome of
the
sections and then if the results are if
different peers agrees or different
peers or the majority decrease the block
is appended which is inherently so full
replicated database system that doesn't
allow any concurrency and the results
that you are seeing is and there are
many more overheads in block chains
which is not just the execution but also
verifying the signatures for each and
every transactions that's a trial yeah
Mike okay so just curious if you could
give us a feel I know you didn't go into
the details of the blockchain protocols
but is there something fundamentally
different with using blockchain as the
backend for the key value store as
opposed to if you were just building a
federated database over a bunch of slow
database systems where you would be
faced with with a lot of the same
challenges so there are two others from
my site to your question there the first
one is so why not using oh why don't we
use why don't you use a database system
or more a replicated database system
from the start for those use cases and
yeah but that's a valid question and so
the the the answer is here so people
from for me people are people are using
block chains nowadays and so and it has
this legal notion that data that is
stored in the blockchain can be used as
evidence for court so there are already
some mechanisms in place that you don't
have for databases so what there are
reasons why people should use a
blockchain so therefore it's it's for
some use cases even more possible to
start with a database system as a
starting point the second one is
regarding the performance I think that
we saw already the talk for example from
Microsoft in the morning there's a lot
of a lot going on in or optimizing the
performance of blockchain systems
themselves and we just benefit from it
so whatever comes next as a platform we
can plug it in as a back-end and use it
and provide verify
verification guarantees on top and this
is what what let's say the the value of
what what we provide is so you get the
interface of a typical database you can
verify your your operate your
transactions or put get operations as if
it would be your database but at the end
it's it's a blockchain so we provide a
stable interface you can program against
it from your application and get the
advantage advantages from you proc chain
systems assume we move from proof of
work to proof of stake and assume every
block in PAC 10 some transactions what
would you imagine will be the next
bottleneck in terms of the improving the
performance of dorchen transaction
processing we haven't been ourselves not
looking too much into where the
bottlenecks of current systems are there
are two good papers about that analyze
actually the performance bottlenecks and
where are the limits of how far could we
push the performance if we tweak the
parameters there's one from a bunch of
authors from ETH Cornell etc I'm where
they threaten as the upper bound with
the current protocols I think that's
that's a nice a nice rate anyway so and
the second one is block bench where they
running already some against different
systems with different consensus
protocols were close
from my perspective so what I think
block chains should do is so the the
computational or the execution of
transactions is inherently inefficient
as I said it's it's completely
sequentialized there's no notion of
concurrency and I think block chains can
learn a lot from what databases have
been doing in concurrency so executing
transactions as if they would be
serialized see if they if they would be
serial but having actually concurrent
execution and if we can get some ideas
of those into the next into the next
generation of blockchain systems it
would increase the performance and
reduce the bottleneck of what what what
current block chains have
all right I think we are like like
running slightly behind schedule so if
you have other questions we might want
to do issue the break so the next
speaker in this session is a Sri nut so
Shri nut is a researcher at Microsoft
Research at the Redmond labs and
sweetness is an expert on you know
having building systems or on like like
verifying of computation our own
computation verification and in this
talk is going to talk about a system
called spice which is about verifiable
state machine and this work is going to
appear at OSD I this year so this talk
is about a powerful primitive called
verifiable state machines and a system
that implements this primitive called
spies this primitive as many
applications in the context of
trustworthy cloud services as well as
decentralized block chains I'll start by
defining what this primitive is the
verifiable state machine is a primitive
in which there are three types of
entities instead of clients a stateful
service and a set of verifiers these
clients issue a set of requests to the
service and get back a set of responses
then the service periodically publishes
a trace which contains an entry for each
request response pair then each of these
very fires run a set of local checks and
then output accept or reject and then we
call such a primitive as a verifiable
state machine if it satisfies these
properties first if the service behaves
that is the execution is equivalent to
some serial execution of the concurrent
request then the verifiers output except
second if the service misbehaves with
the execution of requests or with
concurrency control mechanisms then the
probability that a verifier outputs
accept should be less than epsilon where
epsilon is varies
model third the trace itself is zero
knowledge that is it does not reveal
anything about the requests or the
responses or the internal state of the
service beyond the validity of the
correct request execution finally
require each entry in this trace to be
small for example a few hundred bytes it
turns out there's a lot of prior work
that implicitly implements this
verifiable state machine abstraction
they do not use the state machine
formalism but it's not fundamental the
theory actually dates back to early 90s
but this theory was too expensive in it
could be implemented how there's a lot
of work that reduces the cost of this
theory by all 20 orders of magnitude and
these latter systems so I'd support for
stateful computations in those earlier
systems for example they support storage
interfaces such as key value stores and
even a limited form of sequel databases
despite this massive progress all of
these systems have two key limitations
first the storage operations in these
systems are very expensive for example
it would take tens of seconds or even
several minutes for for each storage
operation second limitation is that they
only support a sequential model of
execution for expressing these services
as a result of these two limitations
prior work can only support very limited
throughput even for very simple services
our system which is called spies
addresses these limitations first it
features a new storage primitive that is
two orders of magnitude more efficient
than prior instantiations second it
supports a concurrent model of execution
for expressing services as a result of
these two are new techniques spice can
support thousands of transactions per
second for many realistic applications
in the rest of the stuff I'm going to
well proof or focus on three things
first I'll discuss a few applications
that can be built with verifiable state
machines second I'll present some
background on prior work and a quick
overview of spice finally I'll present
some experimental results at a very high
level we are interested in this
primitive verifiable state machines for
two reasons
first it enables us to build cloud
services in which we do not have to
trust the cloud infrastructure second it
also enables private and efficient
blockchains both in the permission
membership model and Commission less
membership model I'll start with the
first application scenario the first
application is a cloud hosted ledger
inspired by sequence here the service
maintains balances of assets owned by
different clients and it exposes three
types of requests first the issue
operation enables an issuer which is a
special entity in the system to issue
some assets to a client the second
operation is a transfer that allows one
Cline to transfer an asset to a
different flight finally the last
operation which is called retire allows
a client to take an asset out of the
system so in the status quo if somebody
wants to verify the correct execution of
this service they have to get a complete
trace of all the requests responses and
the internal state of the service but
with spies an auditor can verify the
correct execution of the service without
access to any of the requests or the
responses and it does not have to trust
the infrastructure on which just run
which the services is running
the second application is in the context
of for decentralized block chains such
as aetherium on aetherium a smart
contract is essentially a state machine
where two or more counterparties can
issue transactions to create state
transitions so in the status quo all the
transactions are actually stored on the
blockchain so this provides new
confidentiality guarantees anyone on
anyone in the world can inspect the
internal state of the contract or also
look at all the state transition say
your contract has gone through second
every request from the app must be
processed by the blockchain so this
limits the application level throughput
that you can get by storing a smart
contract on a public blockchain whereas
with verifiable state machines you don't
actually have to execute those smart
contracts on the blockchain you can
execute them outside the blockchain and
then persist only a sussing
zero-knowledge trace on the blockchain
because this sussing trace does not
reveal anything about the internal state
of the requests of the responses it
provides very strong confidentiality
guarantees and because aetherium will
only process the sussing trace you can
actually support very high throughput
for your applications which is
independent of the throughput supported
by it helium
so in the I hope that I convinced you
that verifiable state machines are
actually useful so in the next part of
this talk I'm going to provide some
background on a prior system called
Bentley before I provide an overview of
spies so Pinetree itself extends to
private systems called Tsar and
Pinocchio to support a notion of state
all these three systems are composed of
a front end and a back end this front
end translates a c' program into a set
of algebraic constraints and then the
back end implements an argument protocol
to prove the correct execution of the c
program i'm not going to go into the
details of how these components work but
I'll just observe that both daughter and
Pinocchio support a large subset of C
this in turn enables verifying the
execution of stateless programs and then
thank his support state while working in
the same stateless computational model
by leveraging cryptographic hashes I'm
going to briefly tell you how this is
done so the key idea in Pantry is to
name data blocks using a short
cryptographic digest of those data
blocks here's a very small C program
that illustrates the this key idea in
binary it takes as input it digests and
then the prover of the service can
actually supply state of course because
the service is untrusted it can support
the supply any state to this program but
there's an assert statement that checks
if the digest supplied by that verifier
equals the cryptographic hash of the
block supplied by the service and if
this server service supplies the correct
state just check passes otherwise this
check fails and by using this idea
Pantry builds a key value store the core
idea is to treat hashes of data as
pointers to such data then you can build
a tree and which in turn can be used to
build a key value store
but the fundamental problem in this
approach is that cost of a key value
store operation is logarithmic in the
size of the state completely this means
it takes several minutes of CPU time
even with the million key value pairs in
your state Spice addresses these
performance problems
the core idea in spices be user set data
structure instead of a tree data
structure within map key value store
operations to operations on a set as a
result cost of a storage operation is
constant time instead of logarithmic on
an amortized basis hungry instantiate
this idea knively it's actually going to
be more expensive than the tree based
approach constants involved and in the
case of many data sizes that we are
interested in however spice solves this
problem it does this by using an
efficient instantiation of this based
data structure using elliptic curve
cryptography spice also includes new
techniques to execute these state
transitions or transactions
inexpensively in this model I'm not
going to go into the details of how all
of this is done but I will just present
a few implementation details and how the
system looks the implement spies on top
of pantry we also wrote three
applications using spice but spice
includes a tool chain using which you
can build many more applications the
pull chain takes as input a C program
which expresses a request handler and
then it outputs two executables one for
the service and one for the verifier and
this request handler can include
arbitrary C code and it can also call in
to spices storage api's the storage
primitive itself exposes many api's
first it provides you operations and key
value stores such as get and put
second it allows mutual exclusion API
such as lock and unlock so you can lock
a key perform an update and then unlock
it also provides a restricted form of
transactions so you can call begin
transactions on a set of keys it returns
the current state of those keys and you
then you can do arbitrary computation
and then you can call in transactions
with the values that you want to write
back and all of this update happens
atomically in the next part of this talk
I'm going to present some experimental
results the two questions that I'm
interested in first how to spice compare
with prior state-of-the-art second what
is the intern performance of
applications built with spice to answer
these questions we're on a set of
experiments on an azure cluster so for
the first question we measure the
throughput of key value store operations
and their spice as well as a set of
baseline systems we preload the key
value store with a million key value
pairs and then we measure the throughput
of the system for get input operations
separately as you can see due to new
techniques in spice spice can achieve up
to four orders of magnitude speed-up
compared to the baseline systems so to
answer the second question we
implemented three applications and this
graph depicts interent performance with
varying number of CPU cores and the
x-axis you can see we have depicted
various requests types such as issue
transfer and retire that are supported
by these applications as we can see
spice achieves a near linear speed-up in
throughput has been provide more CPU
cores I did not depict the verifiers
throughput but it's much more than the
provides throughput of the services
throughput which is 15 million proof
verifications per second on the same
cluster
so to summarize the stock we believe
verifiable state machines is a key tool
in in the context of both cloud
computing and decentralized blockchains
spice represents a substantial progress
towards efficiently implementing
verifiable state machines finally we are
excited about the many possibilities
that this work points to with that I can
take it
[Applause]
I'm sorry I kind of lost the connection
between spice and the blockchain so
where exactly are using Spicer
technology to implement blockchains
or is it a front-end to block chains
because using a code generator so I
don't know exactly what the connection
is application the blocking here's the
scenario that I presented in the context
of block chains so instead of for
running the entire smart contract on the
blockchain and then executing the
contract on every node in the blockchain
system you could run it once and then
you could just persist that sussing
zero-knowledge trace in the blockchain
so the entire blocks in network would
just verify that there was a valid state
transition and it does not have to
really cute any transactions and they
also don't need to know what the
contract was or what this contract was
doing so it provides confidentiality and
also scalability so you're basing like a
front-end to the blockchain yes you
don't need to use the blockchain in the
backend you could put in a database sure
yeah the fact that it's a blockchain is
actually not relevant yes
so you only the verifier is running in
the blockchain but you could run that
verify anywhere right and even the
service itself could be running outside
the blockchain using traditional
databases the trace includes all the
hashes of the state
can you return to the slide that gave
the big picture of requests going into
the blockchain and the trace going to
the verifiers yes could you say what
information the verifiers have access to
in order to make the decision if this
picture depicts only an append-only
trace are they aware of other
information yes yes they do know the
specification of the service for example
of what it means for taking a
state-transition so they know the code
that represents the state-transition
they also know some encoding of the
request and the encoding of the
responses so this trace has an entry for
each request response path so the
verifiers are aware of something about
the requests they don't know the actual
request plain text contents of the
request but they have an assasin
encoding which is a commitment to this
request thanks
a quick question while we're on this
slide so you've defined soundness in
terms of some epsilon so what should I
think of epsilon is being like the
internet is very large and there are
many requests so so how often in
practice would you expect soundness to
be violated yeah yeah so this epsilon is
one in two power 128 so you can think of
it as 128-bit security so it should be
very small like that you should
absolutely not see very far accepting
some incorrect statement as correct
except with that one in 1/2 power 128
which is the security of many crypto
primitives that we've
[Applause]
so the final presentation in the session
is by professor han seong from UC
Berkeley so she has a whole bunch of
awards so she's a MacArthur Fellow so
she's a Guggenheim Fellow and MIT via 35
award and she has like several best
papers in security and and learning
conferences and she also happens to be
the co-founder of a start-up in
blockchain called Oasis labs and I I
believe that some of the work she'll be
talking about is based on is is related
to the startup as well okay great thanks
for being here I'm dancing I'm a
professor in computer science at UC
Berkeley and also I'm a founder and CEO
of Oasis labs so today I'll talk about
privacy preserving smart contracts and
skill a new blogging platform that we're
building ok so right so as we all know
data is a new oil and our birth data can
really help us with the valuable data
analytics and machine learning and help
us King as said gain insights in many
different domains including healthcare
financial services and RT however a lot
of data is also sensitive and we are
actually facing a lot of big problems in
the data domain today for example data
breaches and the commonplace now for
example Equifax one of the largest
credit score companies had the recent
breaches were attackers who were able to
steal sensitive information about modern
hundred forty million users and the
other hand a lot of valuable data is
also being silos and
because it is sensitive they couldn't
really be utilized and hence a lot of
data we are not being able to extract
valuable insights from other states
including for example Mexico data and
financial data and so on and also at the
same time users are losing control of
their data as demonstrated in the recent
Cambridge analytical incident so on the
other hand we are seeing that blockchain
is providing a transformative technology
and aiming to solve a number of problems
blood team aims to provide openness and
transparency and allow us to not rely on
any central party and provides automatic
enforcement of agreements so so far what
has protein brothers it helps with
payments with a ce o--'s and crypto
kiddies so the question is I mean in the
future we hope that blockchain can do
even greater things can help us to
revolutionize many different segments in
industry including again financial
services healthcare out in many many
other domains so right so today I want
to talk about some new technology that
we have been developing that actually
helps bring in the blockchain technology
to a broader domain to enable these
other more advanced applications than
the ones that we have seen today and
also at the same time help us solve some
of these and the security and privacy
problems that I just mentioned at the
beginning so first let me give you one
motivating example how in such an
example how
she helped solve the problem and also
where we need new technologies in
blockchain
so this motivating example is in the
area of fraud detection so for example
of a bank they need to do for our
detection to figure out whether they
should give someone alone or whether
they're suspicious are malicious
activities so typically how it works is
that each Bank using its information
country is on fraud detection and
detector and the kettlepizza is
sensitive and usually it's difficult for
different banks to collaborate together
however as we all know the effectiveness
of of this type of models and really
depends on the amount of data that the
model is trained on our the the broad
you know news that the model actually
has seen and hence it would have been
very nice if we can develop a technology
that allow these different banks to
collaborate together and using the data
from each of the banks together to
develop a better machine a new model for
fraud detection fortunately today we
don't have a technology to enable banks
to do this because because of privacy
concerns regulatory risks and the
misaligned incentives so this is an
example where actually blockchain can
help in particular a new type of
technology blockchain technology such as
the ones that we are developing can help
where we can actually develop smart
contract in this case of Frau detected
smart contract they runs on top of the
blockchain and in this case the
different banks each other and country
contribute data to the smart contracts
and together using the data from this
different sources
and the first detectives my country can
chew through our detection model and and
hopefully this practically monitors
train Tooting and data from different
banks can be much more effective and can
really help each bank and to deal with
the fraud much better another to you
neighbor application like this we need
to solve a number of challenges and
issues so first in a typical blockchain
actually all data and compute on the
blockchain is public and in this case we
are dealing with very sensitive data and
essentially users our customers
transactions so we need to handle the
the challenge of having sensitive data
on the blockchain worker nodes
essentially protecting the computation
process of this March contract execution
from leaking sensitive information and
secondly the computer fraud detection
model itself can potentially leak
sensitive information about the inputs
because the maturing the mother here and
that is trained as training from senses
of inputs to start with and I'll show a
little bit later that our work has shown
that even where information in your
model if you are now careful with the
privacy protection the most random
machine in the mountain itself can
actually leak sensitive information
about the inputs and finally to this
blockchain has a huge scalability issues
and to this protein has per performance
and their high costs so again in order
to enable an application like this we
really need to be able to scale up the
blockchain and scalability to enable a
real-world applications like this and
actually add
at the class scale even so that's what
our talk about this yes so we are
actually going to develop a
privacy-preserving smart rancher that
can help save others so in order to
enable application like this and address
the challenges that I just mentioned and
Oasis we are developing a new blockchain
technology called privacy please one of
the key of a blockchain platform is
privacy preserving smart contracts a
skill so first we one of the key
provinces of our platform is privacy
preserving smart contracts and the
privacy preserving strong contract
satisfies a number of unique properties
and capabilities it enables automatic
enforcement of codified privacy
requirements so the privacy requirements
here is coded into the smart contract
and we can enforce this without relying
on an essential party and it's designed
to scale to real-world applications
including heavy workloads such as
machining and we design the technology
to make it easy to use and to in to make
it much easier for developers to build
privacy-preserving applications without
needing to be a privacy expert in order
to enable this privacy preserving smart
contractor scale we developed a number
of different technologies and combine
together to build our Oasis blockchain
platform the Oasis approaching platform
essentially has you can do it as two
main parts there's the platform layer
and the platform component and there's
the application components where the
smart contract is the abstraction at the
application level so at the plot at the
platform level the first
we build confidentiality preserving man
contract execution to protect the smart
country execution process from leaking
sensitive information about the inputs
and at the application level within the
smart contracts we provide capabilities
for privacy preserving analytics and
machine learning to make it easy for
developers to do analytics emotionally
without needing to worry about privacy
and to enforce the other side privacy
policies and at the platform level we
also develop a new architecture for the
blockchain to enable scalable smart
contract execution in particular for
scalability for complex smart contract
execution so now let me talk about each
component technology separately so first
let me talk about the confidentiality
preserving smart contract execution
so typically okay informations so most
blotching today the data and computes
our public on the blockchain
and hence they can only have very
limited use cases so in this case and
the inputs to the smart contract is
public and the smart contracts
essentially then take the inputs and as
a computation and performs a state
transition and also the states of the
smart contracts in most of today's
blockchain platform is also public so
one way to confidentiality presuming
smart contracts execution essentially
here everything's encrypted so the data
is encrypted and also the states is
encrypted as well and the smart contract
essentially and as a computation our
encrypted data and to perform the state
transition and also at the same time we
to ensure that even though the data and
states are encrypted we still want to
ensure that we can have a proof of
correctness that the state transition is
correct so the question is how were
actually enable there's a practical way
of doing computation of encrypted data
and in particular this confidentiality
preserving execution so that's
essentially we do this by leveraging a
composition of different techniques for
secure computation so in secure
computation essentially we have two main
types of approaches the first one is a
secure hard way
the advantage of secure hardware is that
it's a hundred performance it's
performance as close to native
computation and they can support for
general-purpose computation the
challenge for the other types of
approach is crypto based techniques such
as secure multi-party computation for
the homomorphic encryption so on the
challenge for this type of approach is
that the performance overhead can be
very high often times it's all just a
magnitude higher than native computation
and hence they can only be used for very
limited use cases and in the Oasis
blockchain platform we actually use a
combination of these different
techniques and depending on the actual
use cases after smart contracts we use
different combinations of these
techniques to enable confidentiality
presuming execution so now let me just
briefly say a few words about the secure
hardware aspect so the secure Hardware
here and one abstraction is called a
trusted execution environment and also
here we call it the secure Enclave and
the idea of secure Enclave is that's
here we can
run a program in this case asthma
contract inside the seeker on cliff and
the then in this case the operating
system of the application that runs
outside of the secure Enclave will not
be able to tamper with
what's running inside and also will not
be able to see what's running inside and
hence the secure Enclave house provides
integrity and confidentiality after
execution and also at the same time the
how do I provide how to replace the
mechanism for remote attestation such
that the remote verifier can and
remotely verify what has been run inside
the secure Enclave and its initial state
so we have developed a research project
called akedan and leveraging approaches
like this and we provide security proof
using universal composability and we
have developed a number of sample
applications including training
machinery models in healthcare domain
and smart building domain and many other
applications so here one of the key
capabilities that were used to enable
confidentiality preserving smart
contracts accusin is leveraging the
capability of secure enclaves and in
fact the secure unclips can serve as a
cornerstone security primitive even
beyond the application domain of
blockchains
secure unclips can provide strong
security capabilities and can serve as a
platform for building new security
applications that couldn't be built
otherwise for the same practical
performance and over the years so all
the hardware manufacturers have
recognized the importance of building
secure hardware and they all have built
different solutions but however we still
have huge challenges in building secure
hardware for example how secure can be
and the worst hermanos
and what would interests with the secure
hardware and the ultimate challenge is
can we actually create truly trustworthy
secure Enclave as a cornerstone security
primitive that can be widely deployed
and enable secure systems to be build on
top if we can do this then we can truly
I share the whole community into a new
secure computation era so what's the
path towards PT in Chatsworth a secure
Enclave
so first we need to have an open source
design open source design provides
transparency that's needed for the whole
community together to analyze and verify
the security and correctness of the
secure Enclave and that can enable much
higher assurance and also open source
design helps build a community and also
ideally we would like to provide a
formal verification of the secure
Enclave and we want to ensure secure
supply chain management for securing the
manufacturing process so towards this
goal we are doing a project called
keystone on cliff I mean to build our
open-source secure Enclave on top of
risk five trip which is an open-source
RISC architecture that's available today
and we provide strong memory isolation
and many other properties and I would go
to enable open source secure Enclave
that can really be deployed and be used
and with many fractures by any
manufacturer and be used in the real
world and risk five actually has been
what are they adopted in industry the
risk five Foundation has more than a
hundred members and you can find out
more information by Keystone at our
website the Keystone - unclean dot org
and we have a number of goals increased
in the project to help us to to is
finally achieve the goal of beauty
open-source secure Enclave and this is a
collaboration between Berkeley and MIT
and with other institutions joining and
we plan to have first release this fall
both as the deployed on FPGA as well as
actually on the demo chip high five
unleashed the rig's five chip so that's
the first component technology
confidentiality preserving smart country
execution let me and then also quickly
talk about the second component
technology for privacy preserving and
analytics emission and yeah so what
would do this analysis dimensionally
name there is a lot of privacy risks so
for example here there are two types of
questions one so how many trips were
taking in New York City last year and
the other ones how many trips did you
take last week so as you can see you one
question and reflects a trend the other
one actually leak sensitive information
about the individual but to all to and
both territories you actually both need
to actually have access to data and
hence and this is an example showing
that just having access control as
insufficient to be able to protect
privacy and at the same time being able
to answer queries like this and there
has also been proposals using data and
animal vision technologies to solve this
problem but there's also insufficient
and theta an animation can reduce the
utility of data and also at the same
time it provides insufficient privacy
protection there has been lots of
research is showing that anonymized data
set actually one is combined with other
publicly available data set can be used
to re-identify
users and hence clicking census
many of our individuals we were also
doing the recent work showing that you
know when you train a different model
you actually need to be very very
careful so the question here is to
neural networks actually remember
training data and if years can attackers
actually extract secrets in the training
data from just simple recurring the
learned models so in collaboration with
the researchers from Google in our
recent paper here is an example of one
of the case studies we showed that when
we train along with model and the email
dataset in this case it's a public Enron
dataset the email data says naturally
contains credit card numbers and Social
Security numbers of actual users and we
demonstrated that attackers can actually
craft attacks to then by just crying the
language model and to be able to extract
the credit card numbers and Social
Security numbers from the original
training data sets and this is an
example demonstrating that even when you
are training a machine in your model you
have to be really careful to take the
correct measure to protect users privacy
so luckily here we actually have a good
solution and so instead of training and
vanilla dip linear model instead if we
change our differential profits a tip
linear model that in this case both from
our proposal measure as well as attacked
evaluation with demonstrates that's by
tuning a differential profits depend on
your model we can provide a much
stronger privacy protection for the
users so I'm running out of time so I
won't have time to actually go into the
details about differential promises or
the differential privacy at the high
level is essentially a formal privacy
notion that helps to measure for an
algorithm and the editor analytics
algorithm a machine learning algorithm
whether it can distinguish whether a
particular users data has
used in producing that it analytics
results are tuning the machine any model
so the differential privacy provides a
very strong notion for protecting users
privacy in data analytics and machinery
there has been very limited real-world
use of differential privacy including
Google and Apple use differential
privacy in very limited setting and
there's no previous real-world
deployments of differential privacy for
general-purpose analytics and for there
are a number of challenges for deploying
differential privacy in practice in the
real world
equality usability for non-experts broad
support for analytics queries and
machining and also in t is an
integration with existing data
environments there is no previous system
that addresses are these issues in
collaboration with the Whooper we have
developed new systems to address these
challenges and in our system
Kuras and option we essentially develop
techniques and tools to automatically
rewrite state analysis and machine
running pipelines to enforce
differential privacy and as well as
other desired privacy requirements and
some of our technology has already been
deployed as a blueprint for protecting
privacy in the internal data analytics
so putting together confidentiality
preserving smart country execution and
privacy preserving data analytics a
machine learning so this enables the
privacy preserving smart contracts and
now let me just briefly talk about the
third component technology scaleable
smart contract execution again I don't
have a lot of time left so let me just
go over this very quickly and so
typically when people talk about
plotting scalability
one thing that people immediately think
about is blockchain shredding it's like
you have one lane of cars but now you
have you know many lanes in parallel to
improve the circuits
after traffic however this type of
approach is good for high throughput of
simple transactions and power for the
the kind of protections that we want to
build these are also much more complex
and so the different smart contracts can
also depend on each other so to enable
scalability in particular skill ability
for complex smart contract execution we
have designed and developed a different
protein architecture than previous
plug-in architectures and in particular
by separating out execution from
consensus by decoupling the different
function functions that are blockchain
and me is providing so our design is
inspired by a few key observations of
the limitations and challenges in
today's blockchain approaches so first a
blockchain platform essentially provides
a 3 min and functionalities consensus
storage and computes unfortunately in
most of today's blotching platforms are
the three functionalities are coupled
together and has makes it really
difficult to scale and also hear
consensus as the slow operation and as
often the key bottleneck and when we do
shaking coordination also is expensive
and can limit the scalability as well so
to peace on this episode observations
and to address these challenges we
provide we propose an
you bloody architecture for what we call
separately execution from consensus
where we actually decouple these
different functionalities of a blogging
platform where we separate out the
consensus of a the storage layer and the
computer where the the the computer
executes the smart contracts and the
store usually a persistent state and the
consensus agrees on the state
transitions so I think here there's a
little bit of time so I probably won't
have time to go into the details here
and so so essentially two separate
execution from consensus we I guess
right so again the the compute the
computer layer does the computation and
in this case actually the compute nodes
are stateless so now can sense the
protocols are necessary and they can
optimistically I secure the transactions
and in this case the figures have no
effect on the state and the states are
persistent to the storage layer and
where the blocks are persisted and
replicated and again no consensus
protocols are necessary and right in
this case either important and finally
the the state transitions are committed
to the consensus layer and here we use
verifiable computation to verify the
correctness of the computation and the
consensus layer essentially tracks the
states transitions and the transaction
ordering and we use different types of
techniques for verifiable computing
including majority votes and a news a
new approach that we proposed we
developed and discrepancy detection and
we can also use other methods and such
as zero knowledge proof for verifiable
computing so putting all these
technologies together we enable
privacy-preserving smart contracts SQL
and here's one of the application
and that we have been building and
together with other collaborators from
eth and doctors from Stanford as well as
top developers an application called
Carol a privacy-preserving tokenize data
markets from medical data so medically
there is a lot of integer sallows and
and the goal of Kara is to incentivize
doctors and patients to share data and
improve medical research and we want to
provide an easy fast and secure way for
doctors and patients to - to essentially
upload their they head to the platform
and share their data and they can earn
rewards for it
Wow at the same time preserving their
privacy and by utilizing the privacy
preserving smart contracts on top of the
Oasis blockchain the medical researchers
can write their privacy preserving smart
contracts and within the smart contract
it can contain code for training machine
any models as we are the serving machine
any models and also the smart contracts
can specify Terms of Use for example how
users may get compensated for
contributing their data to the smart
contract and also users and patients
they can also specify their own privacy
requirements for their data and if they
agree to the Terms of Use after smart
contract developed by the medical
researchers then they can contribute
their data to the to the smart contracts
developed by the medical researcher once
in smart contracts collect enough data
then they can treat machinery in the
models over the data and and then this
way can help medical researchers and
pharmaceutical companies - and to their
medical research and to help find better
cures for diseases with this approach it
can significantly reduce the friction
for medical researchers and
pharmaceutical companies
get access to data to be able to change
machine any models for for their work
and this is just one of many examples
for the different use cases that
blockchain platform like this can enable
by providing post privacy protection as
well as scalability and we just launched
OSS labs recently we reach the 45
million dollars and we have a lots to
build we actually also have launched our
private test net and we are inviting
developers to join our private tests
nuts to build applications and new
technologies on top of our platform so
at Oasis labs we are building a
promising first high-performance
cloud computing platform on blockchain
new computing paradigm and computing
platform that has a unique combination
of set of properties privacy protection
scalability as well as without needing
to rely on an essential party and we
hope that this technology can really
help enable completely new types of
applications to be built that couldn't
be built today and for more information
you can go to the website thank you
[Applause]
questions hey I'm going back to your
original example right the original
example is there were two banks and you
wanted to build sort of a machine
learning model that combined the data
sets
yeah multiple banks so my question is
can it can't you solve this problem by
just using secure hardware
what is the blockchain connection it
seems like you your unioning data sets
so just encrypt the data register keys
and secure hardware and maybe run our
program inside hardware so what is the
blockchain connection are you afraid of
someone tampering the data
why do you options and you sent your
party so then you don't need to say like
who is operating this so essentially you
have a blockchain platform that people
don't even need to agree like a hole
should be you know chester's or who
should be operating this so it's just
right without relying any central
project in particular in this case like
here I just give an example of a few
pegs but you can imagine that in other
scenario so you can have money parties
and you're not going to have all of them
to agree to reach agreement sound like
who they want to trust the who should be
coordinating and running on these things
so with the blockchain just helps to
write okay
removing but the smart contract code
itself that you register in the Box
chain that will still be public read
that is not encrypted right no question
so in our platform actually this will be
a choice of the developers so the
developer can specify that they wonder
smart country to be pública they can be
fully private yeah in which case they'll
be encrypted
so there's also this company enigma from
MIT and you know I was reading their
white paper and it seems like they were
also trying to solve something very
similar so maybe if you could say
something comparing the two approaches
that would be very helpful in smart
contracts in general people understand
it's its importance so I think actually
I think it's a very good problem for
many people to solve and I think you'll
be great to see the whole community come
together to to overcome this problem and
solve this problem and so our academic
paper is the first paper in a community
that I came out that actually develop
technology and this and and again I
think it's a very important problem we
want to yeah we encourage the whole
community to actually work on us I had
one one follow-up question so in one of
your earlier slides you had approaches
right you you were using secure hardware
using multi-party computation you are
using zero noise proves and potentially
others so my question is like let us
assume that secret hardware is really
secure there are I know there are issues
with that like why do you need other
approaches because want to be able to
solve like say multi-party computation
okay okay yes that's a very good
question
so essentially and one of the mango is
after the oasis platform with this
privacy-preserving smart contracts
primitive and says we want to offer to
make it easier for application
developers to use state of the art
security and privacy technologies
without needing to be experts and also
in this case it will provide a unified
secure computing framework to try to
leverage a combination of these
different technologies and yes if you
really chase a fully trust the secure
hardware then essentially you don't need
to use the other like the crypto based
techniques but however depending on the
actual use use case and also depending
on
developers preference so some developers
they just want to use crypto based
techniques and if their application and
logic is simple enough and they don't
care too much about the performance
overheads
then we are happy to offer them the
choice of not relying on secure hard way
any other questions okay so let's thank
the speaker ring thanks everybody